everything living do they then
not believe
Allah
here says
To those who disbelieve not see
that the heavens and the earth
We're together and we separated
them. What does this mean? Did
any of us see this separation
that took place between the
heavens and the earth?
Obviously, this was before our
creation. It's not something we
can observe now. It's in the
past. Second of all, Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
the heavens in plural, in the
plural sense and the only thing
that we can observe is
singular. One one heaven. That
is the lowest heaven of the
dunya. We can't see all the
seven heavens. You can only see
one. Allah
mentions
in the Quran that he
had beautified and adorned the
heaven of the Duniya with
stars. With celestial bodies.
We understand this to mean that
everything that we see in the
heavens above us are, it's just
part of the lowest level of the
heaven. Lowest heaven, one
heaven. There are still six
above it. How are they? Allah,
we don't know. We can't see
them. So, the question arises.
When Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says to the disbelievers not
see that the heavens and the
earth were one thing and we
separated the two. How can we
see this? We don't even see
this.
The answer is sight here what's
meant by it is knowledge
Allah interchanges the two
throughout the Quran. Knowledge
and vision site. You see
something and knowing something
are interchangeable in the
Arabic language, certain
places. This is one of those
instances. Why is that? Because
that which is known absolutely
and positively. is referred to
as being seen. Right?
is referred to as being seen
Now, for instance,
somebody, we even have this in
English. I mean, it's not
really necessarily unique to
Arabic but let's see if we can
come up with an example of this
in English. For instance,
If somebody, if someone heard
something. On the radio, let's
say.
Wouldn't it be correct for us
to say, didn't you see how he
was speaking? That's normal,
right? We could say that and
it's correct. It's a correct
sentence. Didn't you see how he
was, you know, I didn't see how
he was speaking. I heard how he
was speaking but we understand
that to be the same thing or if
they said something and you
read it, as a text, as a text
message. Don't you see how
they're speaking? This is not
hearing or seeing now. Now, I'm
reading. I know what they said
but we use sight and knowledge
interchangeably, right? Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala said so in
translating this how would we
translate this?
The proper way to translate
because sight articulates
knowledge but not all knowledge
articulates sight, right?
And
so what does this mean?
Everyone who saw knows but not
everyone who knows saw
something. Now, the question
here is how would we translate
this? Site here entails two
things, two meanings, knowledge
and and the act of seeing
something. But when we
translate things, we can't
translate all the meanings.
It's just not possible. It's
not possible to translate all
the meanings because now we're
no longer translating. We're
explaining now. Now, we have
turned it from a translation
into an exegesis. It's not to
translate all the meanings
there are meanings that are
less apparent. There are
meanings that are more
apparent. There are meanings
that are. implied. They are
it's impossible to translate
all the meanings. And it's
impossible to translate word
for word. I know some have
attempted this but this is
something that the scholars of
Islam have prohibited the
literal translation of the
Quran. This is prohibited in
Islam. Because it conveys the
wrong set of meanings and
what's intended by something
that is said or words is their
meanings. Not necessarily their
structure.
Also, the scholars have
mentioned that it is, even if
it were permissible to
translate word for word, it
would be impossible. It's not
possible due to the different
ways that verbs are used and
the different ways that
sentences are structured in
Arabic and English. It's not
possible to translate Arabic
into English word for word or
any other language for that
matter. understanding this by
translation If we are to
translate, we have to choose
the most relative meanings. How
do we choose? We can't include
all the meanings. You just
can't. So, we have to choose
some of those meanings and
translate them. Which meanings
are the ones that get the
choice
are are going to be chosen in
our translation. They are going
to be the meanings that are
most pertinent, the meanings
that are most obvious, and the
meanings that are clear by the
context.
the contex
t is going to put
everything into perspective
Theref
ore, in translating
something this, we
wouldn't translate it as You
those who disbelieve not see
that the heavens and the earth?
Because this will articulate a
meaning that is undesirable and
would
necessitate
translation would
necessitate explanation and so
forth. Rather, do those who
disbelieve not see or not know
that the heavens and the earth
were once one and we parted
them. We separated them. and we
made of water everything that
is living. Life is two types
as the scholars mentioned,
there are things which are
alive by way of a soul. Then
alive by way of growth and
reproduction. These things
don't necessarily have a soul
trees and vegetation and
bacteria and you know, things
this. These are things
that are living because we see
that they change and they
metamorphosize but they don't
necessarily have a soul. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
that everything that is living
he has made from water.
We know that This includes the
human beings, includes all of
the living things that we can
see or discover. But we know
that the gin are created from
fire. Are they are created
from? The edge of fire. So how
is it that They can be created
from fire, wouldn't they fall
into the generality of this
verse? The answer is First of
all, just because the gin were
created from an essence, an
essential material that is
derived from fire, doesn't mean
that they are still fire. That
is not correct. Just we
are created from dust, from
dirt, from clay. We're not
clay. We're not dirt. have
changed from that original
thing into something completely
different now.
and so, this is a question that
some people ask sometimes. It's
kind of a bothersome question
People will ask things such as
How will the can be punished in
the hellfire if they are
created from fire. This is such
a silly question. And these are
questions that honestly the
antagonist of Islam ask when
they try to make fun of Islam.
This is the kind of questions
that they ask. As if this never
occurred to any of the
companions. This never occurred
to any of the the prophet noone
has never occurred to any of
them and now it occur to you
because you know and you think
and they didn't think a very
silly notion How is this
possible? Well, first of all,
this is going to be an issue.
This is going to be problematic
for the creation. This is not
problematic for the creator.
That's the first thing. Second
of all,
Just because they have been
created from fire, doesn't mean
that they still are fire. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala tells us
that the will enter paradise
and paradise has water in it.
It has rivers. It has coolness
in it. All of these things
which are the antithesis of
fire. Yet, they will enjoy it
as human beings will enjoy it.
and so, these types of
questions become sometimes
other questions and other forms
the prophet tells us that
when a person is placed in his
grave, two angels will come to
him and sit him up in his grave
and will ask him three
questions. So, they'll ask,
well, how can you sit up in
your grave?
That's really what you learned
from the narration. That's the
only thing that you learned of
all the things that this
narration is about That's what
we took away from it. We took
away how do you sit up when
you're in your grave? And it's
it's interesting because the
prophet never found to ask that
question. The companions never
found to ask that question. And
the scholars of Islam
throughout the throughout the
centuries have never found to
ask that question. Because it
an unquestion. That is not a
question that you would ask.
It's a silly question. It's
based on the premise that this
life and the next life are the
same thing. I hope people ask
other questions well,
let's say a very terrible
person dies today and a person
who's not so terrible dies
before, who's less terrible and
this one that is less terrible
has been in the ground being
punished in his grave for
thousands of years and this one
who is more terrible is not
going to be punished in his
grave as long. Riddle me that,
right? As if time is something
that you can calculate in the
grave. You calculate time just
you calculate time here
with the quartz stone and and
These are questions that person
who has respect honestly, first
of all, the nature of these
questions is troubling in
themselves. I understand that
not everyone who asks these
questions has ill intentions.
Sometimes, people are just
curious. Yet, the basis of
these questions If we were to
compare these questions with
the questions of the antagonist
of Islam, they would be very
similar. They asked the same
kind of questions. Those who
make fun of Islam make fun of
the prophets and messengers
throughout human history. This
is the kind of questions that
they ask. They ask these
questions. Right? The prophet
tells them that he went to Al
Aqsa and came back in one
night. Oh how could you do
that? None of the companions
asked that. Not one. None of
said, how did you do that?
Because they understood that
that's not the point of the
statement. He said he did it.
He did it. I don't need to know
how it happened. It happened.
Now, what am I supposed to take
away from this? That's what a
Muslim says. Ones who ask this
question were the non Muslims.
The antagonist, the ones who
were trying to make fun of him.
They said, oh, how did you do
that? Huh? It's a monstrous.
How'd you do that? Prove it to
us. Show us how you did it.
What kind of animal did you
ride? Who came to you? What did
he say? What did you say? Where
did you go? This is the kind of
thing that they ask. In an
antagonistic spirit. The
prophet says, when a person is
placed in his grave, the two
angels will come and they will
sit him up and ask, hang on a
second. Wait, you said sit him
up? How are they going to sit
him up? He's in his grave. Is
that something a Muslim would
ask the prophet
Companions heard this. They
didn't take that away. A Muslim
will listen to this statement
and say, well, it's going to
happen. I don't know how but it
will and how doesn't really
matter. It is going to happen.
So, what I'm what is my
takeaway from this statement?
Why am I being told this? Well,
I'm being told this to you to
be better to derive these
lessons. This is what the way a
Muslim thinks. A non Muslim
thinks with this kind of
hermeneutic of of suspicion
Hey, hang on. How is he going
to sit up in his grave? Oh, oh
yeah, oh yeah? Where are they
going to come from? There's no
way that they could get in
there, huh? Right? It's not
open. It's all closed up. Are
they going to open the
graveyard? How are they
going to do? This is the
questioning of someone who is
looking for a problem with what
is being said. Someone who is
suspicious of what is being
said at the least,
antagonizing, at worst.
Islam is built upon belief in
the unseen. Nature, the unseen
by its very nature is that it
is unfathomable. It is super
rational. We don't know how to.
We don't know how it is because
we have nothing similar to it
and that which is seen. We have
no parallel. This is how we
understand things. We have, for
instance, the nature of time.
What is time? Well, when time
happens, certain things happen.
Right? We refer to this as a
third dimension. When time
elapses, things decay, things
tend towards chaos, etcetera.
This is how we understand time.
But when we look at infinity
That mean, infinity means that
time essentially doesn't exist.
That's what that means. Do we
know what that means? We don't
really know what that means. I
mean, we understand what the
meaning, the concept is in
theory but we've never seen it
before. And even if we are
experiencing it, we still won't
really fully grasp the
magnitude of eternity. Because
we still haven't seen it. This
is, this is new to us, right?
and this is how the unseen
works. We have things in
paradise can only be imagined
in a very fantastical sense Can
I can I write a book about the
physics of paradise? Of course
not. You have rivers that flow
above ground without any
riverbeds. And you have silver
that you can see through but it
is transparent but it is silver
at the same time. Those things
are opposites. How can that
happen? There's no sun but
there is light and there's also
shade. What does that mean? Why
is their shade if there's no
sun and if there's no sun, how
is their shade? I mean, light
has to be coming from some
direction
etcetera, etcetera. These are
not questions that a person
asks. Just because paradise is
described to us, doesn't know,
doesn't mean that we know how
it is. We don't. Even with all
these vivid descriptions, we
still don't know what they
mean. Oh, the prophet said,
that Allah has prepared for his
righteous servants, a place the
likes of which no eye has ever
seen, no ear has ever heard,
and has never been imagined.
So, no matter how much we sit
and imagine paradise even by
the description of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala, we still
haven't imagined it. Why?
Because we have nothing to base
our imagination on. Yeah, we
have names but that's the only
thing that's similar in
paradise, just the name. Common
name Everything else is
completely different.
[Arabic recitation]